The answer is 96.
The first thing that we need to do is
evaluate what's inside the parentheses
which is 6 squared- 10.
We should treat what's inside the
parentheses as a unique expression and
follow the order of
operations to evaluate it.
So exponents will need to be
simplified first, 6 squared is 36.
So the expression inside
the parentheses becomes 36- 10.
And our full expression
becomes (36- 10) * (4- 8).
Next, we subtract within
the parentheses and 36- 10 is 26.
So with the expression inside
the parentheses simplified to 26,
we can rewrite our full
expression as 26 * 4- 8.
Now we should multiply 26 * 4,
which gives us 104.
And our expression becomes 104- 8.
And when we subtract 8 from 104,
we get 96.
It's important to write out
all the steps you are taking
as you do these problems.
Otherwise, it will become difficult
to keep track of what to do next.
I also recommend you do
one thing at a time.
Let's try another practice problem.